biohazard warning
if your signal is gonna be weak hey
there fellow division agents is going to
give you a quick set of tips to help you
increase your success rate in the dark
zone tip number one do not go alone form
up a squad and if you don't have a squad
start using that proximity chat because
you're going to need it at level 8
you can match make for the dark zone so
you should try that as well going into
the dark zone alone is asking for
trouble can you do it
sure but it'll definitely be more
difficult with the team on your side
you're able to watch each other's backs
tactically position to cover multiple
points and help each other with heals in
addition you can become a nice meat
shield for teammates if you happen to go
rogue when going alone you run the risk
of getting gunned down by other teams
with little chance of survival tip
number two learn the lay of the land
it's important to understand the map the
terrain and key locations the landmark
areas are where you'll be able to fight
enemy AI to get contaminated drops to
extract in the landmark areas you'll
find named AI bosses which we usually
drop sweet here another important spot
to know on the map are the extraction
points when you're at the extraction
point you can shoot off the flare
anywhere within the designated zone get
to a good spot so that you can avoid
being surrounded by AI and also monitor
incoming agents one of the best skills
to use an extraction point is the pulse
kill because it'll show you how many
people are around you if you feel it's
not safe to try to extract your precious
cargo you might just want to run away or
wait it out tip number 3 always restock
restock your ammunition and medical kits
add the check points and safe houses
here you can also check out what the
dark zone vendors are selling to make
sure to check their gear out and buy any
upgrades you see fit however if you can
hold off and save up for the high-end
weapons at the safehouse I would highly
suggest getting them the high-end
weapons have more perks and are
generally a lot stronger than the stuff
you'll find the safehouse vendors seem
to cycle out weapons every 24 hours or
so so be on the lookout tip number four
don't loot just a loot be selective on
the loot you pick up because you can
only hold up to six items at a time to
extract I know it's hard to fight the
urge to loot but
selectively if you happen to gather too
many items you can deconstruct the items
you don't want in order to make space
for the better items try to sash up as
many Blues as you can before extracting
also make sure to visit the HQ from time
to time after extractions so your stash
doesn't get pulled if it gets full you
won't be able to extract any items out
of the dark zone tip number 5 when to go
rogue if you ever decide to go rogue
make it count
the agents want a target are the ones
with brown satchels on their back this
signifies that they have some loot also
you're going to want to make sure you
have space to take the loot that they
have otherwise you're gonna end up in an
awkward situation where you want to pick
up the items but need to run away before
getting killed if you do go rogue one of
your best strategies will be to run away
until the timer is up the moment you
fire again at an agent your timer will
reset so beware
going rogue can be worth it especially
when you can manage to stay alive until
the timer runs out because it'll net you
good experience and money however if you
die it'll cost you around 300 dark zone
dollars and a good chunk of experience
which brings me to my next tip tip
number 6 always be on the hunt you
should always hunt rogue agents because
it will give you a lot of dark zone
experience and money in addition they
might have some sweet loot to acquire
too when hunting rogue agents try to pin
them down before actually shooting at
them if you can't kill them in a few
shots it's probably not worth slowing
down to shoot them continue to chase
them until they stop and try to pin them
down until other agents can come to
provide backup all in all the best tip
is probably not to trust anyone unless
they're actually in your squad hopefully
these tips helped you and if I missed
any leave them in the comments below
stay tuned to games.com for continuing
coverage of the division
you